well could we soon see the end of Resort
fees this week the White House says it's
working to do just that now President
Biden
Biden is taking aim at what he calls
hidden junk fees and those include those
that are charged at local Resorts Sasha
Loftus joins us in the Las Vegas Strip
with more on how this could change your
next hotel stay
people we spoke with here on the strip
tonight say they love the idea of no
resource
tell me this could actually change the
way they book vacations here in Las
Vegas
Resort fees no one likes them but we all
have to pay them they sell you the eight
hours a night or twenty dollars a night
and it's oh by the way you got the
resort fee it's that extra 30 to 45
bucks a day you're charged when you book
a hotel room but there's a chance it
could all go away this week President
Biden announced a plan to make things
like Resort and concert fees along with
some Bank overdraft charges illegal I
think something like this going away it
could just lead to better transparency
in people making better choices UNLV
gaming historian David Schwartz says if
this were to happen many resorts could
just raise their prices but at least
visitors would know what they're paying
up front I think it will provide more
transparency and pricing which is
usually a good thing and it'll just give
people a better idea of exactly what
they're getting into when they go to
book it's an idea most locals say they
can get behind you know what you're
paying it's like that piece so annoying
to enhance their experience in a city
they already enjoy so much tell me up
front when I'm paying now last week the
Federal Trade Commission did begin a
rule process to quote get rid of these
particular junk fees but no word on when
or if this will impact us here in Las
Vegas reporting on this trip tonight
social Loftus 8 News Now